[Music]
spider-man into the spider-verse has
just received its world premiere and
like most modern marvel movies the film
doesn't stock just because the credits
start rolling throughout this video I'll
be breaking down everything you need to
know about the post-credits cameo that
comes after the film there will of
course be heavy spoilers so if you don't
want to know anything just yet then I
highly suggest that you turn off now but
everyone else
I'm definition and welcome to the
channel where I ruin it so you don't
have to in the post-credits scene of
into the spider verse we joined
spider-man 2099 played by none other
than Oscar Isaac there were rumors that
Isaac was cast in the film over a year
ago and it's great to see him behind the
first Latin Spider Man in his New York
apartment 2099 uses a web slinging
gadget that allows him to hurl across
the universe to earth 66 earth 66 like
its namesake as the 1967 cartoon that
aired during the 60s on CBS the show
recently saw a resurgence with a number
of memes so it's brilliant to see every
surface here as 2099 arrives at Earth 67
he bumps into that universes spider-man
and the two Spidey's recreate one of the
show's most famous means fans will
obviously lap this up and I adored
seeing the meme play out on the big
screen it's clear that Sony have some
big plans for the expansion of the
spider-verse
and I can't wait to see what they are so
what are your thoughts on the
post-credits scene of into the spider
verse I already know you loved it so
leave your comments below on what you
think this could be saying up if you
enjoyed this video then please like it
and check out my breakdown of this
week's other big comic book thing The
Walking Dead's midseason finale which
will be linked at the end of this video
this is the channel for people who are
super into superheroes so if that's the
kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this I've been definition you've
been the best and I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
you